the 2019 hurricane season officially
starts tomorrow
government forecasters predict 9 to 15
named storms 2 to 4 could become major
hurricanes that's a category 3 or higher
but the ability to predict those monster
storms may be threatened by the next
generation of cellphones mega Oliver is
on the Atlantic coast in Sea Bright New
Jersey meg that's an area very familiar
with the devastating effect of
hurricanes Anthony good morning you are
right people here still remember the
impact of Hurricane sandy and how much
they relied on early warnings from
forecasters on one side of the debate
scientists worried that future 5g
technology will interfere with satellite
data they rely on on the other hand
federal regulators and cell phone
providers are racing to deploy 5g
technology hurricane season is here and
with it the potential for the next round
of deadly and devastating storms but
this year meteorologists say they're
also keeping an eye on a new threat 5g
will change everything
the powerful cell phone network known as
5g which will deliver information up to
100 times faster than today's mobile
networks we push speed as far as we can
push it this is a huge concern because
we fear that advances in weather
forecasting art risks meteorologists are
concerned because some of the
frequencies the Federal Communications
Commission plans to use for 5g are
located next to the only frequency where
weather satellites can detect water
vapor a critical component for accurate
forecasting they worried the new 5g
transmission will interfere with their
weather data collection making it less
accurate the milky shades of white and
gray are water vapor these are being
detected from space how critical is that
data the data is essential in a 90
percent of data going into forecast
models these days come from weather
satellites if you remove a good portion
of that satellite data you're crippling
our ability
make accurate weather forecasts that
could mean less time to prepare for
major storms
if fived you were in place during
hurricane sandy and we had the
interference that many of us expect we
might not have seen nine days out that
storms going to make a left we might
have only known three days out that the
storm would make a hard left into New
York and New Jersey
the FCC declined an on-camera interview
but a group representing the wireless
industry calls the meteorologists
concerns an absurd claim with no science
saying the weather sensor currently
deployed is much less susceptible to
interference than meteorologists claimed
a lot of people in the wireless industry
say these fears are overblown they're
all exaggerated what's your response to
that I don't want to find out if they're
overblown I'm certainly in support of 5g
and advanced telecommunications but
let's have a conversation to make sure
we're not setting weather forecasts back
several decades there is still time for
a compromise before networks roll out 5g
later this year we don't want to move
backward we want to move forward with
our weather prediction capabilities
because lives property and even our
national security depend on it
NOAA says that accurate weather
forecasting adds 13 billion dollars to
the US economy but cellphone providers
say 5g technology would add 274 billion
dollars so there's the money aspect of
this as well
meantime meteorologists fear that if
they lose some of this critical data it
could set them back to the 1980s in
terms of forecasting Gale given us
something to think about Meg we we open
this segment with it's raining men you
seen any men falling from the sky I need
to rush down thank you back a beautiful
day at the beach thank you so much